they're ashamed of their debts for weeks
this couple has been without electricity
bills have piled up they owe the
electricity company more than five
thousand euros but they live below the
poverty line and can't pay in
desperation they've turned to a group of
activists called n plural no which
translates as I don't pay I didn't know
what to do so I asked the group for help
I even called the government to ask for
payment to be deferred
my daughter's going back to school and I
need to buy food to cook her meals the I
don't pay movement is popular in Greece
the activists go down to the electricity
meter with their tools and switch the
power back on they don't believe that
what they're doing is illegal they say
they're simply switching the supply on
they're not stealing any electricity the
public utility companies beg to differ
but the activists say it's about making
a political point in the next few months
pressure on debtors will mount more
people will lose their homes we'll
demonstrate our solidarity with these
people who are under pressure because
they can't pay their debts a growing
number of Greeks are at the mercy of
creditors in the next few months some
300,000 homes could be seized by the
state or the banks
when the homes are put up for auction
the activists from I don't pay try to
occupy them they're usually successful
the police tend not to intervene and the
creditors get unwelcome publicity
most of them refused to speak to the
media they feel they're made to look
ridiculous in videos the activists post
on the Internet Christo's Tomos in oti
DS is unemployed the activists prevented
his home from being seized by occupying
it he joined the I don't pay movement
himself when a court was about to
confiscate his home when I write in
court I hadn't realized that a
demonstration was planned I was so happy
when I saw the activists I owe the bank
2,400 euros they were going to seize my
apartment and put it up for auction for
just 80,000 euros for now banks and
authorities can get as tough as they'd
like they've got the law on their side
the left-wing Greek government had
promised to protect the poor and ensure
they could keep their homes but in
response to pressure from Greece's
creditors what's known as the cuts ailee
law was relaxed Anna course Anu is a
lawyer she gets dozens of calls every
day from people who fear they'll lose
their homes is growing public anger and
desperation these people have nothing
and the government promised it would
cancel their debts that didn't happen
instead there have been tax hikes that
makes people even less likely to pay off
their debts
thanks to the I don't pay activists the
couple from Athens whose electricity was
turned off can turn the lights on again
but they're still worried their home
might be seized that's my greatest fear
I've already consulted a lawyer even
though I can't really afford him he's
going to see if we can be let off as an
exception all we can do is hope undreds
of thousands of other Greeks can only
hope as well and into the country's debt
crisis is nowhere in sight